you know where i'm standing right now
i'm in one of my favorite cities in the
world and i am standing exactly
where one of the greatest leaders of all
time martin luther king
gave a speech i have a dream is where he
stood
that's where the audience was this is
also the same place where
our president barack obama spoke at
uh president harding i believe i think
billy graham and several other people
back there
is where forrest gump was chasing down
jenny
yeah this is where martin luther king
stood i love this city because
not only what it stands for the history
you learn so much about leadership when
you're in the city and one of the
conversations that came out last night
we had a chance to meet a few senators
and today
had lunch with a very famous royal
family
that we were invited to by the way right
behind me
this is the man abraham lincoln
but the question was brought up of
when the student is ready the teacher
will appear you ever heard that before
where people say you know when the
student is ready the teacher will appear
when the man when the
student is ready the master will appear
when the student is this the teacher
will look
we've heard in so many different
versions you know this is what it is and
have you ever
questioned that have you ever questioned
that statement
because i don't necessarily know if it's
accurate let me explain to you what i
mean by that um
everybody who's watching this
everybody's a teacher everybody um
a teacher is not somebody that's just
superior to you
everybody's a teacher you're a teacher i
have two boys my three-year-old is a
teacher 318 month old
my nephew is a teacher to my
three-year-old
my niece is a teacher to my
you know nephew
it doesn't matter at whatever levels we
go even the bad habits we learned as a
kid
you know somebody was a teacher teaching
us the bad habits and the good habits
everybody who's watching this is a
teacher
many times we think you know when the
student is ready you know the teacher
will appear we're all
only students where i think we're all
students and teachers because the
statement really is if you want to do
anything great
it's not just about when a student is
ready the teacher will appear it's about
when a great teacher is ready
thousands of students will appear
when the teacher is great a flock of
students
will appear when the teacher is ready
thousands will appear you know why
because um
i can tell you every time i speak to
somebody oh my goodness my business has
changed i'm a whole different person i
can't believe what's taking place
remember they had our biggest
revenue i've made more money this year
than i've ever made we're growing we
can't even stay in the same office
anymore we need new staff we need new
employees we need new support
we need new everything because of growth
and they said why do you think this has
happened it's just like i got lucky no
you became a better teacher you became a
better leader
and when you become a better teacher and
a better leader you purely
attract better talent you attract
quality people you attract people that
want to be around you attract people who
want to be
taught by you who want to be your
students who want to work with you want
to
be around your presence because
you're becoming a better teacher and the
reality of it is
we're in a place right now with that man
right there you know all he did
is he became a better teacher lincoln
became a better teacher and
thousands and millions
voted for that man to become a president
because what he did was a revolutionary
civil rights movement how much criticism
he got and eventually
he got killed a few blocks from here
he got shot at ford theater a few blocks
from here
and a man over there martin luther king
who
spoke and there was tens of thousands of
people here
and he had meetings with presidents he
taught
the presidents he taught people
president lincoln taught people they
became better teachers
yes they're students as well because
they're also being taught
but they eventually became a great
teacher and i think if anything
you get from this message is instead of
always just
being a student also work on being a
better teacher as well
because with being a better teacher
comes a
bunch of students for you to choose for
you to to for you to lead for you to
coach for you to teach
and you'll have the choice to pick them
it won't be the other way around there's
nothing like
a teacher having choices on who they
want to teach and believe me a lot of
teachers take a liking into somebody
if a great teacher took a liking into
you let me tell your life's going to
change
if somebody was incredible teacher and
very wise decided to like you and put
time and effort into you i can't tell
you the things that could happen
i'm a byproduct of it
many people will buy product anybody
that ever does anything great as a
byproduct
so anyways today's message very simple
if the teacher is great thousands of
students
will appear if you agree or disagree
comment on the bottom post a question
and uh thanks for watching this episode
and make sure to please subscribe online
take care everybody